how many we have like 200 000 is it 200
000 years of recorded human history
right you guys have to understand that
people
birthing caves like it There's a western
notion that if you don't have every
single thing you're not gonna be okay
you do realize in certain parts of the
world we're not going to have certain
diseases because we can't have those
diseases we haven't I'm not going to say
people can't be depressed but I promise
you this depression is not gonna be the
same way because people have to get to
work there's no time to be depressed
when you have to feed Africa is not the
same here you can have 10 kids over
there if you can't feed them No One's
Gonna Give You a house no one's going to
give you no benefits that's it's not the
same type of things over